package of sanctions
last week Russia has escalated the
invasion of Ukraine to a new level
the shamra for render organized in the
territories that Russia occupied
are an illegal attempt to grab land and
to change International borders by force
the mobilization and Putin threat to use
nuclear weapons
are further steps on the escalation path
we do not accept the Sham referendum
and any kind of annexation in Ukraine
and we're determined to make the Kremlin
pay
for this further escalation
So today we're together proposing a new
package of biting sanctions against
Russia
the first part concerns the listing of
individuals and entities that will be
presented by the HIV features Apparel in
a moment I want to focus on the second
part of these sanctions
um that will further restrict trade
by that we isolate and hit Russia's
economy even more
so we propose sweeping new import bans
on Russian products
this will keep Russian products out of
the European market
and deprive Russia of an additional 7
billion euros in revenues
we're also proposing to extend the list
of products that cannot be exported to
Russia anymore
the aim is here to deprive the kremlin's
military complex
of key Technologies
for example this includes additional
Aviation items or electronic components
and specific chemical substances
these new export bans will additionally
weaken Russia's economic basis
and will weaken its capacity to
modernize
we will also propose additional bans on
providing European services to Russia
and the prohibition of EU Nationals to
sit on governing bodies of Russian
state-owned Enterprises
Russia should not benefit from European
knowledge and expertise
the search
complex is concerning Russian oil
as you know Russia is using the profits
from the sale of fossil fuels to finance
its world
concerning Russian oil you might recall
that we have already agreed
to ban Seaborn Russian crude oil in the
European Union
as of December 5th
but we also know that certain developing
countries still need some Russian oil
supplies but at low prices
thus G7 has agreed in principle
to introduce a price cap on Russian oil
for third countries
this oil price cap will help reduce
Russia's revenues on one hand and it
will keep the global market for energy
stable on the other hand
so today in this package here we are
laying the legal basis for this oil
price cap
and my last point I want to focus on is
our efforts that we are stepping up to
crack down on circumvention of sanctions
here we are adding a new category
in this category we will be able to list
individuals
if they circumvent our sanctions
so for example if they buy Goods in the
European Union bring them to third
countries and then to Russia this would
be a circumvention of our sanctions and
those individuals could be listed I
think this will have a major deterring
effect
our sanctions have hit put in system
hard
they have made it more difficult for him
to sustain the war
and we are increasing our efforts here
and moving forward with that I would
like to give the floor to you Joseph
thank you madam president good afternoon
with the illegal referenda organized by
Russia
the Kremlin is following the same
Playbook that we have already seen in
Georgia in 2008 and in Crimea in 2014.
as the president has said we condemn in
the stronger possible turn and I am sure
I can speak on behalf of the member
stage of the European Union that none of
them will recognize this falsified
outcome
and we go to the International Community
to do the same because this sham
referendum is a pure violation of
international law and the principles of
United Nations chart
we will continue supporting Ukraine
we stay on course
our strategy is working our ascensions
are having a compelling effect
as the president has explained with the
extension of the list of products that
will be banned from export to Russia we
will continue weakening their military
capabilities
also from the personal point of view we
are increasing the listing of persons
and entities which has been sanctions
they are more than one thousand and
three hundred people or entities
these list targets key decision makers
oligarchs senior military officials and
protagonists
responsible for undermining the Ukraine
curatorial integrity
in direct response to the latest Russia
escalation escalation
for example to calling 300 000 soldiers
to the war
we propose to adopt additional
restrictive measures against those
individuals who are supporting
facilitating or benefiting from the
invasion of Ukraine
president to summarize the new package
of individual designations that will
Target the following people
first those involved
in Russia's occupation and illegal
annexation of areas of Ukraine
we propose to designate the proxy of
Russian authorities in Dominics and
lusank and Gerson and zaporiza
another Russian individuals who are
organized and facilitated the Sham
referenda in these four occupied
territories of a grade
second we propose a number
of designations in the defense sector
this includes high-ranking officials the
Russian minister of defense
those who support the Russian Armed
Forces
by providing Army equipment and weapons
including missiles and fighter aircrafts
and participate on the recruitment of
this 300 000 Celsius
three we also continue to Target actors
who spread this information about the
war
in particular those spreading false
information and donating funds to the
Russian occupied areas
in the category of economic actors a lot
has been done already
but we will add further key operators
and among these operators it will be
people who not necessarily Russians
but people who participate on the
circumvention of sanctions because it's
clear that there are some phenomena of
the convention of sanctions that has to
be included in our listings we are
preparing the listings in order to also
Target these people
and finally it's also important to note
that we extend the geographical scope
of the restrictions applying to Crimea
to the donisk and lushank that were
approved at the beginning of the year
and this will cover all non-governmental
control areas of Ukraine
including the oblast of separation and
cursion which are not part of the zombas
and we are not part of the previous
decisions
I think Madam president that with that
we complete our package of sentience
sanctions work centers matter
but they have to be maintained over time
and ensure that they are not
circumvented thank you
[Music]